one of the things that's happening in
organizations is that more and more work
is being done in teams and one of the
problems that we face as executives in
these organizations is how do we get the
most out of those teams MT is is about
leveraging the power of teams to move
you and your organization forward I
decided to come to MT is because it
gives me a different perspective I just
wanted to learn and retool and after 20
years at the firm from the world's top
professors innovation is a lot of what
we do but with the kind of disruption
that's going on at the moment a big
booster shot of innovation as part of
what we need it turns out that the
skills you need to lead teams have some
overlap with the skills you need to lead
organizations but there are also a lot
of other unique skills that you need for
managing teams there are lots of
practical exercises and not just theory
to help you absorb the concept it made
me think about attitude towards power it
showed me what produces innovation and
what helps blasts it was really focused
on my problem
they showed me this is why this is
happening it gave me a solution as well
I'm really looking forward to bringing
some of the creative energy and the
process ideas back to our team they're
least 10 things I think I can use back
home to be a more effective team leader
I would absolutely recommend this
program the faculty are extraordinary
they're deeply knowledgeable about their
craft their work and just inspiring
people I now have the tools to go back
to my company and build the teams that
we need to be successful